for the rangers it'll be the former
padre jordan lyles a guy who pretty
recently nearly threw a no-hitter maybe
even a perfect game for san diego so pro
far on first one down manny machado is
hitting four straight at the plate
we're good strike three called and
machado down looking
two away first striker of the night for
lyles
and for the padres it's the texan chris
paddock 25 year old right-hander from
austin he attended cedar park high
school low has struggled recently at the
plate last two games over seven two and
one to nate lowe the pitch is a fastball
stroke to left field pam going back he
makes the catch and a hard hit line
drive is out number three here in the
first no runs no hits and air and kinder
valeta left at second base
there are two outs there is no score for
jonah heim who hit his first big league
home run
on tuesday
that came batting right-handed he's
hitting 286 with a home run
and one run batted in payoff pitch to
heim that's hit deep toward the right
field corner it is hooking and it is off
the wall
time on his way to second base and he
slides in there with a double
so the hitless string for the rangers is
over so now white with a chance to break
the scoreless tie right-handed batter
playing center tonight
the 2-2 offering
that's drilled to left field fam racing
toward the line and he won't get it it
one hops the wall and the score is heim
white to second he's digging for third
the throw the dive he's safe for the
triple
and the rangers lead it one to nothing
hey guys 40 yard dash how much of a head
start do you need to beat eli white
20 yards well yeah i'm more worried
about getting hurt and being able to
complete the 40-yard dash so
i would say he's definitely twice as
fast as i am yeah i think i think i'd
have to have 25. yeah 25 to play it safe
and then some kind of carrot
at the end of the line that's going to
keep me motivated to even run those 15
yards a donut or something that works
and good speed aboard with connor falefa
coming up
and the pitch that drill to left center
it's a base hit rolling toward the gap
it is cut off deep in the alley by fam
both runners score izzy's in at second
with a double and the rangers lead it
three to nothing
he certainly hit it where they ain't
that time
as they gave him left center and that's
exactly where he ripped that one now
here's dahl who laid down a sacrifice
but in the first
dahl sends one out towards deep right
center field wish him going back deepest
part of the ballpark back by the 410
to end the inning rangers get three runs
thanks to a couple of extra base hits
rbi triple eli white two run double
isaiah kiner falefa and we go to the
third inning with texas in front three
to nothing so one away and here's manny
machado the 1-0 pitch is hit on the
ground near short is he has it he flips
to solace for one on the first they got
him both
six four three double play wipes out the
threat so
despite the fact that padres had the
bases loaded they do not score here in
the third we'll go to the bottom of the
third rangers continue to lead three
nothing fourth inning back in texas with
the rangers on top three to nothing
four five and six coming up here for the
padres hosmer myers and cronenworth
scheduled to bat in the inning
jordan lyles back out on the hill
and hosmer hits him in the air to deep
right center field eli white going back
and it is gone home run into the bullpen
eric hosmer gets his third and the
padres are on the board
third home run of the season already for
eric hosmer and the padres are on the
board very quickly here in the top of
the fourth there are two on the tying
run at first base the go ahead run at
the plate and the person of fam who hit
into a double play his first time up
no balls and two strikes they set an
outside target and the pitch to fam is
lined to right going back gallow he will
get there to make the catch deep enough
to get another run home will myers trots
towards the plate steps on the dish and
this is a three to two game in the
fourth inning line drive sac fly by
tommy fam his first rbi of 20 21.
kim the number nine hitter for the
padres shortstop leading off kim kind of
stands with that that front foot only on
its toes weights on this curveball and
hammers it deep down the left field line
if it's fair it's gone it hits the pole
it is a home run for hassan kim he's
first in the big leagues and this game
is three to three here in the fifth
welcome to the big leagues hassan kim
so a runner at first and one out in a
tie ball game and eric hosmer came out
osmore popped his short in the first and
then launched a long home run to lead
off the fourth
here's the 01 offering
[Applause]
out to right field that's a base hit
gallow comes up with it quickly he's got
a good arm machado going for third and
then another great defensive play inning
over what a throw by joey gallo the gold
glove winner in right
and we remain tied
one run two hits
and one man left here's ikf isaiah kyner
falefa
he won a gold glove at third base last
year he's at shortstop now there was a
time he caught for the rangers he was
their backup catcher
three and one there's a swing and a long
drive to left this one's way back and
that ball is history
isaiah kind of philippa with his second
home run of the year
puts the rangers back in front four to
three
it's been a very good night here for
isaiah
here's tommy pham tying run aboard for
the padres
one out in the top of the sixth inning
benjamin at the belt to the plate
swinging the ground ball deep short
backhanded by izzy on a knee the second
for one the first double play the fourth
of the game turned by the rangers
that ball was smoked but kind of falafel
with a really nice play moving toward
the hole and sliding to a knee
the two ball gets the rangers out of the
inning again no runs a hit nobody left
middle of the sixth still four three
rangers
top of the order for trent grisham oh
for two of the walk of his own
in the air down the right field line
towards the corner and that ball is gone
a two-run home run for trent grisham
and with one swing to the bat the padres
take a 5-4 lead
trent grisham down the line in right to
the corner and the padres lead at 5-4
so runner on first still just the one
out padres lead five four in the seventh
and manny machado at the dish
profile on first one out in the top of
the seventh inning ball in two strikes
the pitch to machado is swung on and
lifted out to deep right center field
white going back he will slide in front
of the wall it will bounce off the wall
and roll all the way away profar is on
his way home he will score manny is at
second base with an rbi double that just
missed going out 6-4 san diego in the
seventh as will myers stands in myers
one for three he's singled and scored in
the fourth inning the one strike pitch
swing and a bouncer past spores charged
by connor felefa good throw to low in
time to get myers for the final out in
the inning but the padres
grab the lead
left up to hassan
right hander against the left-handed
pitcher swings of the first pitch ground
ball shortstop connor falefa left in the
backs got it throw to first gets away
and that'll get another run home 7-4
it simply went through the webbing of
his glove
and manny is coming up with the sacks
full and two outs
here's the set the payoff pitch
strike recall
fills him with a fastball
and the sides retired the padres settle
for one unearned run on three hits and
an error they leave him loaded throws
his bat which is kind of an automatic
especially if you're looking back toward
the umpire in his direction
whether you said something or not and is
going to get you tossed every time
and manny machado puts his manager quite
honestly i take it back that's when he
got thrown out
to hey to the last hope the rangers need
to get tahedeh and connor felefa on and
then dahl would get a shot at the tying
run
base is empty two outs two balls and two
strikes on to hayda mullanson delivers
and that is grounded to the left side
it'll be kim left of the bag at second
throw to first in time that is the ball
game and that is a winner